Glenn Whitney from Renaissance capital
quit the hedge fund business and he
started the National Museum of
mathematics with a terrific Board of
Trustees they built this wonderful
institution here in New York City and
it's about math America's way way behind
in math and we got to get the kids and
their parents engaged in sides a lot of
fun but this is a serious business we
got to get better at math okay what are
we doing here oh my god there I go it's
actually very easy I flunked this this
is serious math people trying to get a
seventh grader fired up right do that
well the first thing we do is getting
something to touch people learn by
through their hands by touching and
doing I go faster than you four five six
like a hexagon right mathematics and
algebra is not just about numbers and
formulas it's also in almost every
instance about the physical space of
geometry
what do we need to do in this country to
turn around to make math cool it's great
you know I have to like this where they
can touch and feel then you know these
kind of toys I'm always looking for toys
to keep their brain going
do you let him do the machines throw
them into the Pacific Ocean
okay kids to get these math skills in
school but we never show them what they
connect to in the real world we never
show them some of the light at the end
of the tunnel so we're here to show
people the beauty of the applications
and then we rely on the great math
teachers that we have to let them get
the skills what I will do for
mathematics